le roi c'est michel aumont a été
formidable et sa fille c'est vous
ouais et alors qu'est ce que c'est que
cette jeune femme elle est à l'ena il
nous en parlerons tout ça tout à l'heure
vous aime pas fait ce très distingué
princesse c'est une princesse et sa
merde vous arrivez dans sa vie un
playboy qu'est ce que c'est c'est eh oui
c'est un playboy
ces conditions là c'était difficile
c'est un playboy qui à la suite d'un
pari va me plaît pas comme j'ai pensé
dément
québec veulent des choses alors écoutez
moi je lançais confettis chaque fois ce
play-boy intervient donc dans
l'existence de cette patience est court
et ils vont en arriver à as épousé nous
allons regarder la répétition du mariage
car tous doit se passer dans la
convention bien établie